george clooney is world famous but he is
also really really private
until now welcome jonathan bennett our
guest co-host today thank you so much
entertainment tonight that's the song we
have so much ground to cover
don't worry you'll get a chance to sing
um you have a new hallmark christmas
movie we're going to talk mean girls but
first
george is doing a lot of talking as gq's
man of the year revealing things we
never knew
about a mall and his devastating
motorcycle accident
split my helmet in half
it was bad and i was just waiting for
the switch to turn off clooney describes
the 2018 crash
in terrifying detail when i hit the
ground my mouth
i thought all my teeth were broken out
george tells gq he recently had
neck surgery for a resulting disc
problem
amal banned george from ever riding
again george broke a rib after a
previous motorcycle crash in 2007.
you don't want to be in another
motorcycle accident either i don't and
there is there absolutely is that
concern the 59-year-old oscar winner
also talks about how a mall
changed his mind about marriage i don't
foresee it in my future
he says i didn't know how unfull my life
was until i met them all
and then everything changed and i was
like oh
actually this has been a huge empty
space i'm not mad at anything i got
a brilliant beautiful wife as for life
during the pandemic
while george and amal are sticking close
to their la home to avoid risk factors
their three-year-old son has asthma
while amal works remotely george says
i cut my own hair and i cut my kids hair
and i'm mopping and vacuuming and doing
the laundry and doing the dishes
every day and while clooney's not above
doing chores
he also hasn't lost his charming sense
of humor check out how he got julia
roberts to do ocean's 11.
i didn't know her i'd never met her and
she was making 20 million dollars of
film and we just
talked brad into doing it and matt into
doing it and we wanted julia to do it so
i put the 20
bill on the script and i sent it to her
and i said i hear you get 20 a picture
[Music]
now